Ich habe einige Male versucht,
aufzuhören.
Aber das waren maximal drei Wochen.
Danach wurde ich wieder rückfällig,
weil die psychische Abhängigkeit
viel schlimmer ist.
In dieser Reportage
spreche ich mit Menschen,
die Medikamente wie Ritalin
missbrauchen,
um ihre Leistung zu steigern
oder damit zu dealen.
10 Fr. für eine Tablette -
das ist aber teuer.
Je nachdem auch 20 oder so.
"Es geht sicher auch ohne Ritalin,
aber mit Ritalin
schaffe ich mehr in kürzerer Zeit."
Ritalin
hat eine aufputschende Wirkung.
Man spricht auch von legalem Koks.
Der Missbrauch
kann fatale Folgen haben -
von psychischer Abhängigkeit
über Angstzustände bis zum Tod.
Ich dachte nie, ich könnte sterben,
oder das ist zu viel für mein Herz
oder meinen Körper generell. Nie.
Wohin kann missbräuchlicher
Ritalin-Konsum führen?
Dieser Frage
gehe ich in dieser Reportage nach.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Seit ich 18 bin,
habe ich ein Rezept für Ritalin,
weil bei mir eine Schlafkrankheit
diagnostiziert wurde.
Ich persönlich
nehme Ritalin ziemlich selten.
Eigentlich nur, wenn ich
trotz meiner anderen Medikamente
nicht wach bleiben kann
und eine Seite siebenmal lesen muss,
bis ich ansatzweise mitbekomme,
was dort steht,
weil ich aufgrund von Müdigkeit
nicht denken kann.
Es fühlt sich dann an, als hätte ich
sieben Tage nicht geschlafen.
Da hilft kein Power Nap,
nicht früher ins Bett gehen.
Da bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig,
als zum Ritalin zu greifen,
denn es macht meinen Körper und Geist
wieder wach.
Der Wirkstoff Methylphenidat,
der in ADHS-Medikamenten
wie Ritalin enthalten ist,
ist Amphetamin-ähnlich
und hat eine aufputschende Wirkung.
Ähnlich wie Kokain -
nur ohne euphorischen High-Effekt.
Während ich mit Ritalin
auf ein normales Level komme,
versuchen andere,
damit ihre Leistung zu steigern.
Eine Art Hirndoping
oder Neuroenhancement.
Ob das überhaupt etwas bringt,
kläre ich später in dieser Reportage.
In meinem Umfeld kenne ich einige,
die zum Lernen solche Tabletten
schlucken oder geschluckt haben.
Eine davon ist Sophie,
eine Bekannte von mir.
Sie möchte anonym bleiben,
wir chatten via Whatsapp.
Erzähle mal, wieso du Ritalin nimmst.
Sophie schreibt: "Hauptsächlich,
um in kurzer Zeit viel Text lesen
und verarbeiten zu können,
v.a. bei Seminararbeiten."
Würde es denn
nicht auch ohne Ritalin gehen?
"Doch,
es geht sicher auch ohne Ritalin."
"Aber ich schaffe mehr in kürzerer
Zeit, wenn ich Ritalin nehme."
"Ich kann dann an einem Tag so viel
erledigen wie sonst in drei Tagen."
Ich fragte sie, wieso sie es nicht
für die Arbeit nehme.
Denn Studium oder Arbeit
sind doch fast dasselbe.
Sie schreibt, sie verspüre
Nebenwirkungen vom Ritalin.
Sie werde extrem zittrig
und sehr antisozial.
Kontakte mit Menschen würden sie
sehr schnell nerven bzw. überfordern.
Wenn sie das Ritalin
für die Uni nehme,
sitze sie meist alleine
in der Bibliothek
und werde in der Regel nicht
von anderen Menschen gestört.
Ich frage sie, ob ihr die Neben-
wirkungen nicht zu denken geben.
Es sei natürlich nicht gut
für den Körper, wenn er so reagiert.
Genauso wie zu viel Koffein
nicht gut ist.
Aber weil sie das Ritalin
aus einer sicheren Quelle habe,
wisse sie, dass es sauber sei.
Deshalb mache sie sich
nicht allzu viel Gedanken.
Danke für die Auskunft.
Ich suchte noch andere Leute,
die Ritalin missbrauchen,
die ich nicht persönlich kenne.
Es ist wie ein offenes Geheimnis:
Viele Leute kennen Leute,
die Ritalin missbrauchen,
aber niemand
will wirklich darüber sprechen.
Denn jeder weiss ganz genau:
Es ist ein Missbrauch und illegal.
Ich werde immer wieder
von Leuten gefragt,
ob ich ihnen mein Ritalin verkaufe.
Diese Erfahrungen machen auch andere
mit einem Ritalin-Rezept.
Einige schreiben mir,
sie würden es auch verkaufen.
U.a. Manuel.
Mehr Auskunft
wollte er mir leider nicht geben.
Er schreibt: "Ich kenne
viele Jugendliche in meinem Alter -
ich bin 16 -,
die Ritalin regelmässig nehmen
oder zumindest einmal
konsumiert haben."
"Viele bekommen es verschrieben."
"Es wird aber auch oft weitergegeben
und verkauft."
Genau das macht Simon auch.
Mit Simon spreche ich über Facetime.
Auch er möchte anonym bleiben.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Simon.
Du hast selbst schon Ritalin
weitergegeben. Wie läuft das?
Jene, die wissen,
dass ich Ritalin habe,
oder es von anderen wissen,
die fragen mich danach.
Wie viel
verlangst du für ein Ritalin?
10 Fr. oder so.
10 Fr. für eine Tablette -
das ist aber teuer.
Ja. Je nachdem auch 20 Fr. oder so.
Wir sprechen von 20 Fr.
für eine Tablette.
Es ist nicht so, dass man immer
für 20 Fr. verkaufen kann.
Zum Vergleich: Meine 200er-Packung
Ritalin kostet etwas mehr als 60 Fr.
Und das zahlen deine Kollegen?
Oder Fremde?
Wenn nachher
die Vorteile so gross sind,
denken sie schon,
dass es sich lohnt.
Hast du dir schon Gedanken
über deine Verantwortung gemacht,
weil du dieses Medikament
unerlaubt weitergibst?
Ich habe kein schlechtes Gewissen
oder so.
Es landet deshalb
auch niemand auf der Strasse.
Ich finde es nicht so schlimm.
Weil es Leute mit ADHS oder ADS
verschrieben bekommen,
meinen viele,
es könne gar nicht so schlimm sein.
Simon verkauft seine Tabletten
v.a. an Bekannte.
Eine der bisher grössten
internationalen Studien
zu Neuroenhancement zeigt,
dass fast die Hälfte
der 100'000 Befragten
Ritalin und Co.
illegal von Bekannten erhalten.
So begann es auch bei Patricia,
die sich bei mir gemeldet hat.
Ich bin heute unterwegs zu ihr.
Patricia
nahm zehn Jahre lang Ritalin,
weil bei ihr
ADHS diagnostiziert wurde.
In den letzten drei, vier Jahren
lief es aber ziemlich aus dem Ruder.
Sie begann, Ritalin zu missbrauchen
und überschritt ihre Dosis massiv.
Ah, ich muss hier stossen.
Hallo.
Erstmals habe ich es
in der Kantonsschule genommen.
Dort habe ich es von einem Freund
erhalten und es dann genommen.
Ich hatte wirklich das Gefühl,
dass mich Ritalin "normal" macht.
Ich konnte mich gut konzentrieren,
ich war in sozialen Situationen
viel besser.
So nahm es seinen Lauf.
Nach dieser Erfahrung mit Ritalin
liess sie sich auf ADHS abklären
und bekam von einem Psychiater
ein Rezept für Ritalin.
Was war deine Maximaldosis?
Am Anfang war diese ganz normal.
Es begann mit 30, 40 mg.
Plötzlich kam ich an einen Punkt,
da hatte ich das Gefühl,
es reicht nicht mehr.
Ich wollte immer mehr nehmen.
Nachher ist es wirklich ...
- Warum?
Ich hatte das Gefühl, es sei nicht
genug, meine Leistung genüge nicht.
Ich steigerte die Dosis
auf 170, 180 bis 200 mg.
Wirklich sehr, sehr viel.
Zum Vergleich: 80 mg ist die maximale
Tagesdosis für einen Erwachsenen.
Bei mir war es so:
Als ich damit begann,
im Anfangsstadium,
hat es wirklich
viele Probleme gelöst.
Es macht einen
irgendwie viel besser.
Damals ging ich zur Schule.
Das Wichtigste in diesem Moment ist,
dass man die Matura macht,
dass man diese gut macht.
Danach war es der Bachelor.
Ich wollte nichts anbrennen lassen.
Aber du hast es
schon darauf angelegt,
dass du es wirklich bekommst?
In der Abklärung
macht man diverse Tests.
Ich ging aus der Überzeugung dorthin
und auch
aus einer gewissen Verzweiflung.
Ich wollte Ritalin
auf legalem Weg bekommen.
Ich wollte niemanden besuchen,
um es mir illegal zu besorgen.
Ich habe die Fragebogen usw.
dann auch so ausgefüllt,
dass kein Risiko mehr bestand,
dass ich es nicht bekommen würde.
Ich habe mir immer gewünscht,
erfolgreich zu sein,
alles im Griff zu haben,
immer die Beste zu sein.
Und das Ritalin gab mir die Chance,
genau das zu sein.
Ich dachte,
ich genüge den Ansprüchen nur
und sei nur erfolgreich
und gut für die anderen und mich
selbst, wenn ich Ritalin nehme.
Patricia fährt heute
zu ihrem ehemaligen Psychiater.
Jahrelang verschrieb er ihr Ritalin,
ohne zu merken,
dass ihr Konsum überbordet und sie
in eine Abhängigkeit schlittert.
Gemäss meiner Recherche
wird man schneller abhängig,
wenn man Ritalin ohne
medizinische Notwendigkeit nimmt.
Ich frage mich, ob Patricia
vielleicht gar kein ADHS hatte.
Mein ADHS war nie so schlimm,
nie so intensiv.
Es hat mich nicht
lebensunfähig gemacht.
Ich habe psychisch
nicht extrem darunter gelitten.
Ich habe ab dem Zeitpunkt
darunter gelitten,
als ich wusste,
wie das Leben mit Ritalin ist.
Vor fast genau zwei Jahren nahm
Patricia zum letzten Mal Ritalin.
Vom einen auf den anderen Tag
hörte sie damit auf, aus Angst.
Es war für mich der Weckruf,
den ich brauchte, um zu merken,
dass es zu viel ist
und ich mir überlegen muss,
wie ich mein Leben lebe.
Was ist denn damals
an diesem Tag genau passiert?
Ich ging an diesem Tag
ganz normal arbeiten.
Mir ging es nicht gut.
Ich bekam weiche Beine,
und dieser Zustand hielt an.
Es war
wie ein Kreislaufzusammenbruch.
Danach ging ich zum Arzt.
Dort haben sie alles angeschaut,
es gab auch ein 24-Std.-EKG.
Es hat mich
ziemlich eingeschüchtert,
dass sie alles abgeklärt haben.
Ich merkte:
Ich muss irgendetwas ändern.
Heute will Patricia
mit ihrem ehemaligen Psychiater
über ihren Missbrauch sprechen.
Sie hat ihn nicht mehr gesehen,
seit sie Ritalin abgesetzt hat.
Zuvor hatte sie ihn nur besucht,
um Ritalin zu beziehen.
Wirkliche Gespräche zwischen
dem Psychiater und ihr gab es keine.
So bekam er auch nie etwas
von ihrem Missbrauch mit.
Es wurde dann ja
auch immer mehr Ritalin.
Das hätte doch auffallen müssen.
Deine Medikamente
waren ziemlich schnell weg.
Ja, das dachte ich auch.
Aber ich war natürlich schlau.
Bzw. habe ich ausgerechnet,
wie gross der Abstand sein muss,
um auf meiner normalen Dosis
zu sein.
Deshalb machte ich Pausen,
was man nicht tun sollte,
wenn man Ritalin nimmt.
Zwei oder drei Wochen
habe ich es nicht genommen.
Klappte das mit den Pausen?
In diesen zwei Wochen
ging es mir eigentlich immer so gut,
weil ich so frei war,
mich selbst war.
Ich war glücklich,
ich konnte lachen,
ich konnte an Gesprächen teilnehmen.
Ich war eine bessere Freundin,
eine bessere Kollegin - alles.
Wieso dann Ritalin,
wenn es dir ohne besser gegangen ist?
Weil ich das Gefühl hatte,
ich könne nur damit performen,
meine Leistung bringen.
Ich könne nur so genügen.
Darum ging ich immer wieder zurück.
Es war aber immer auch
ein trauriger Moment,
weil ich diese glückliche Person
in diesem Moment
hinter mir gelassen habe.
Patricia erzählt
auch von Nebenwirkungen.
Viele sind nicht atypisch
und kenne ich auch.
Doch bei ihr haben sie
ein extremes Ausmass angenommen.
In den letzten zwei, drei Jahren
habe ich pro Nacht
etwa 3-4 Std. geschlafen.
Dann Appetitlosigkeit.
Ich war damals auch 10 kg leichter.
Ich war auch nicht liebevoll,
überhaupt nicht, sondern sehr kalt.
Ich hatte generell
ein Desinteresse an Menschen,
an meiner Familie und Freunden.
Ich war stets nur
auf etwas fokussiert.
Hast du dich nie gefragt,
ob das nicht etwas fahrlässig ist?
Ich dachte nie,
dass ich sterben könnte.
Oder dass es zu viel für mein Herz
oder meinen Körper generell
sein könnte.
Bei 200 mg bekäme ich wahrscheinlich
einen Herzinfarkt.
Ich trank zusätzlich noch Koffein,
Cola Zero, alles Mögliche.
Wahnsinn.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie das mein Körper ausgehalten hat.
Aber das merkt man irgendwie nicht.
Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl ...
Jetzt bin ich so sensibel
gegenüber solchen Dingen,
auch wenn ich nochmals Ritalin
nehmen wollte, ich könnte es nicht.
Mein Körper
könnte damit nicht umgehen.
Ich hätte zu viel Angst vor dem,
was passieren könnte.
Nachdem Patricia das Ritalin
endgültig abgesetzt hatte,
bekam sie plötzlich Panikattacken.
Diese haben sie
besonders verängstigt.
Das möchte sie
nicht nochmals erleben.
Sie holte sich Hilfe
bei einer neuen Psychiaterin
und machte eine Verhaltenstherapie.
Zu ihrem vorherigen Psychiater
wollte sie nicht mehr gehen.
Die Scham war zu gross,
ihm zu erzählen, was passiert ist.
Bist du nervös?
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Heute Morgen und letzte Woche schon,
aber jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Ja.
Beim Gespräch bin ich nicht dabei.
Wir werden aber später noch
ein Gespräch zu dritt führen.
Ich informiere mich
über die Verbreitung
des Missbrauchs von Ritalin und Co.
Die bisher grösste Studie
zu diesem Thema zeigt,
dass in 15 untersuchten
Industrieländern
der Missbrauch
von solchen Medikamenten
von 2015-2017
extrem zugenommen hat.
Im Schnitt hat sich der Konsum
fast verdreifacht.
Eine andere Studie zeigt,
dass in der Schweiz
4,1 % der Studierenden
schon zu Ritalin und Co. gegriffen
haben, um ihre Leistung zu steigern.
Diese Studie
ist aber schon fast zehn Jahre alt.
Ich möchte
aber trotzdem noch wissen,
wie gut sich Ritalin und Co.
als Neuroenhancer eignen.
Dazu zwei Experten der Schweizer-
ischen Fachgesellschaft für ADHS.
Das ist ja
eine ganz spannende Frage:
Wie ist es bei Gesunden,
die Ritalin nehmen?
Da hat sich gezeigt,
dass es wahrscheinlich nicht
über den Placeboeffekt hinausgeht.
Aber den Placeboeffekt
darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Man wird wach, aber die Leistungs-
fähigkeit nimmt auf Dauer nicht zu.
Es ist wie bei Ovomaltine: Man kann
es nicht besser, aber länger.
Genau, genau. Aber ob das dann
wirklich auf Dauer...
Es hilft vielleicht kurzfristig.
Aber ob das auf Dauer gut ist
und die Leistung über
das gesamte Studium besser wird,
möchte ich stark bezweifeln.
Für mich ist extrem wichtig,
nicht einfach nur
die Ritalin-Schachtel auszuhändigen,
sondern ich muss die Patientinnen
und Patienten begleiten.
Das ist psychotherapeutisch ...
Das ist eigentlich ein Rundumpaket,
das man wie immer in der Medizin
individuell anpassen muss.
Es gibt nicht d i e Therapie.
Manche brauchen
keine Verhaltenstherapie,
aber Coaching ist sehr wichtig.
Was wir natürlich
manchmal haben, ist,
dass Patienten sagen: "Das
Medikament funktioniert so gut."
"Ich will keine begleitende
Psychotherapie mehr machen."
Ein 16-Jähriger möchte vielleicht
nicht zu Dr. Kupferschmid gehen
und über seine Probleme sprechen,
nimmt das Medikament
aber doch ganz gerne.
Weil er merkt, dass es ihm hilft.
Das ist eine Entscheidung
des Patienten und der Familie.
Ich empfehle immer was Zusätzliches
zu den Medikamenten.
Ich will die Patienten
irgendwann mal wieder sehen,
selbst wenn sie
gut eingestellt sind
und es nur
um die Nebenwirkungen geht.
Da muss man wirklich sicher sein.
Es kann ja doch mal
eine Blutdrucksteigerung kommen
oder irgendwas am Herzen sein.
Wenn man es dann
nach und nach steigert,
muss man sich
natürlich auch überlegen,
ob überhaupt ADHS vorliegt.
Denn es ist ja gerade spannend,
dass die meisten Menschen mit ADHS,
die auf solche Stimulanzien
respondieren,
eben gerade nicht
süchtig davon werden.
Letztendlich
ist eine Suchtentwicklung
auch bei der richtigen Diagnose
nicht ganz auszuschliessen.
Die Experten sagen also,
es sei wichtig,
die Leute zu begleiten,
die Ritalin verschrieben bekommen.
Bei Patricia
passierte das aber nicht.
Hätte ihr Ritalin-Missbrauch
dadurch vermieden werden können?
Während unserem heutigen Gespräch
zu dritt möchte ich
den ehemaligen Therapeuten
von Patricia darauf ansprechen.
Wenn man mit einer Therapie
gearbeitet hätte,
wäre es dann nicht
plötzlich aufgefallen?
Wenn ich all die Patienten,
die wegen ADHS mit Medikamenten
behandelt werden,
auch noch in einer Therapie
unterbringen wollte,
also nur unterbringen,
geschweige denn selber machen,
dann hätte ich sämtliche Therapeuten
der Grossregion
vollgenagelt mit Patienten.
Das ist die Realität
in der Versorgungssituation.
Meine Devise,
da spreche ich mal für mich:
Psychotherapie
ist sinnvoll, notwendig,
wenn Zweiterkrankungen da sind -
davon gibt es genug.
Was würden Sie empfehlen,
um eine Sucht zu vermeiden?
Eine Sucht ist auch
die körperliche Abhängigkeit.
Sie hatten ja sogar die Fähigkeit,
tagelang Medikamente
nicht zu nehmen,
um sie dann zu nehmen, wenn Sie
Spitzenleistungen abrufen wollten.
Aber es war ein Missbrauch,
eine missbräuchliche Einnahme.
Bis 11 Uhr, 12 Uhr
ging es jeweils ziemlich gut.
Am Nachmittag kippte es.
Um 17 Uhr
hatte ich dann eine Art Tunnelblick.
Ich konnte mich teilweise
nicht mehr richtig bewegen,
weil ich wie gelähmt war.
Wenn Sie quasi schon auf dem Optimum
Ihrer Gehirnleistung sind,
können Sie durch eine Stimulanz
die Wirkung oder Ihr Gehirn
nicht zum Superbrain machen.
Aber wenn das Optimum überschritten
wird, auch mit der Dosis,
dann wird z.B.
die Konzentration schlechter,
die Unruhe und die emotionale
Labilität werden höher.
Ich befürchte, da Sie sind auch
in eine Falle getappt.
Die eigentliche Problematik
von Patricia sei nicht das Ritalin,
sondern ihr Verlangen nach Selbst-
optimierung und Bestleistung gewesen.
Ein Phänomen, das Dr. Kasper
nicht selten beobachtet
in unserer Leistungsgesellschaft.
Wie geht es dir jetzt
nach dem Gespräch?
Ich muss sagen,
ich fand es sehr interessant,
auch seine Sichtweise zu verstehen.
Ich fand es auch spannend,
dass er sagte,
dass es nicht als Sucht gilt,
sondern dass es ein Missbrauch war.
Mir geht es etwas besser,
das so zu hören.
Denn Sucht
ist ein extrem starkes Wort.
Er hatte viele gute Punkte.
Auch wieso es mir
so lange geholfen hat.
Es hätte mir nicht geholfen,
wenn ich nicht irgendeine Form
von ADS oder ADHS hätte.
Es ist erschreckend,
was ein Medikament auslösen kann,
wenn man es falsch anwendet.
Besonders für mich,
die selbst auch Ritalin nimmt.
Patricia ist durch ihren Missbrauch
kalt und lieblos geworden,
nur noch ihre Leistung zählte.
Und diese ist durch das Ritalin
auch nicht besser geworden.